Un somni.
La mare de totes les aventures.
La travessa de travesses.
Un repte impossible.
Quina païssa.
Mare de Déu.
La volta al món a peu. Catalans sense fronteres.
Benvinguts a Enric Adventures.
Us presento el projecte més gran
de la meva vida. La volta al món a peu.
En català.
Un dia vaig descobrir que el caminar
és la manera més primitiva de viatjar.
Aquí és que ens connecta de manera més profunda
amb la Terra i les persones que l'habiten.
Fruit d'aquesta inquietud vaig obrir el meu canal de YouTube.
Per compartir les meves travesses i inspirar altres,
igual que altres em van inspirar a mi.
La ruta començarà a la plaça Catalunya de Barcelona.
Hi cremaré Europa per França, Itàlia, Eslovènia,
Croàcia, Bòsnia, Montenegro, Albanya,
Grècia i entraré a Àsia per a Istanbul, Turquia.
Seguidament enfilaré el nord seguint la costa del Mar Negre
fins a Georgia i Armènia,
on agafaré un avió fins al Paquistan.
Continuaré per Índia, els Himalaias,
travessant el Nepal i baixant a Bangladesh.
A Dhaka volaré fins a Tailàndia,
recorrent el sud-est asiàtic fins a Singapur,
passant per Malèisia.
El tercer continent serà Austràlia.
Recorreré més de 4.000 km des de l'extrem est,
Perth, fins a l'oest, Sidney.
A continuació travessaré Amèrica del Nord,
pels Estats Units, des del Pacífic fins al golf de Mèxic.
La part més difícil del viatge serà Sud-Amèrica.
Començant pel Perú, recorreré les seves muntanyes
i entraré a Xile, on creuaré el desert de Takama
i travessaré la serralada dels Andes
fins a l'oceà Atlàntic a Argentina.
Per últim, volaré fins a Santiago de Compostela
per fer el camí de Sant Jaume en sentit invers
fins al punt d'inici final, la plaça Catalunya de Barcelona.
De camí, em trobaré a 20 catalans a 20 països diferents
que m'explicaran com viuen la cultura catalana tan lluny de casa.
Tot plegat, ho documentaré a l'estil Enric Adventures,
gravant, editant i pujant els vídeos en ruta.
I com no pot ser d'una altra manera, en català.
26.232 quilòmetres, 4 continents i 3 anys,
dormint en tenda de campanya i cuinant amb fogonet.
Sí, mama, menjaré bé, sí...
Acompanyeu-me.
Gràcies.